let's let's actually jump back to our
government overreach conversation and
then after this we'll jump to super
chats okay
so man this this one really bugged me
the New York Post more than 1500 NYC
inmates have been released during the
corona virus crisis I don't get this
some a week ago
well it makes sense all right you got a
bunch of people in close quarters they
can't go anywhere they're getting sick
and maybe it makes sense to put him
under house arrest I mean not only that
but house arrest makes more sense for
everything to be honest well I did read
that it's it's like blue collar slash
like nonviolent right that kind of stuff
so I don't know it's not I'm not
necessarily agreeing with this but it
isn't necessarily worse than it seems
you know this because this is a scary
like you never know it's like 1,500 like
criminal oh no man they're like there
was one story about a murderer who got
release and then went murdered some way
yeah the next day well there you go bro
let me tell you a story I I took a
Community College course for about a
month on criminal justice when I was 18
okay first I'll explain this the secret
to life you don't need a high school
diploma to go to college you couldn't go
to a community college once you turn
eighteen and go and you take one course
for you however cheap it is and then you
put down some college in all your
applications some college yeah I'm a
high school dropout that's that's the
loophole but anyway I chose some class I
thought were fun feeder acting okay
and I did a criminal justice class and
we learned about this murderer there's
something called the exclusionary rule
what is what bench girl call it the the
fruit of the the fruit of the poisonous
tree yeah yeah so if if the police
acquire evidence by violating your
rights that evidence can't be used in
court right awesome awesome rule well
there was a story about a guy who had
like murdered a bunch of people and he
gets pulled over the cops illegally
searched his vehicle because they knew
he's the cop knew he was a suspect and
got these murders so he illegally stops
the guy all right and then he illegally
illegally detained him and searches the
vehicle boom finds hard evidence like
blood or something okay
so they arrest him the DA is like we got
him and then once they get ready to gear
up his lawyer says what was the reason
for the stop and lo and behold the cops
I don't know who's a suspect and the DA
is like no like why it's a Fourth
Amendment violation ya can't just stop
random person cuz you it cuz you think
dude got released and you need did
killed somebody the next the next day
did it well so this is anecdotal and
possibly apocryphal but like almost
immediately he kills again and and then
the craziest thing was and this is a
story I was being told by the teacher so
I don't know how how true it isn't you
could look it up apparently they find a
dead body outside of his apartment like
not eat just in plain sight and so they
go to him and he's like oh I did yeah
and they were like they were like what
whining I was like they're like why
didn't you try and get away with it he's
like oh you caught me already something
like that what now it's been it's been
like it's been 16 years I think okay so
long ago that was 16 years ago no no
since I was told that stories are told
it may have been in the eighth of
something so long but the point of the
story was to explain that even though we
recognize how you can lose like and you
could some people can get hurt the
Constitution's Constitution okay police
cannot violate this so so going back to
the inmates being released right yeah I
do think it from a civil liberties
perspective it makes sense I do not
think the state has a right to lock you
in a box full of sick people if you want
if you want to talk about you have to
get in there in the first place
I mean I'll guard your eyes and go home
yeah come back now you got the people
locked in these tiny rooms yeah this
this this actually goes into the
governor's abuse of power because there
have been numerous studies even studies
that a China showing that people outside
are substantially less likely to catch
kovin okay it's in your home in your
office in jail interesting be well it
makes sense I mean like we're in this
room it's not that big right so if you
like coffee you're gonna splatter the
wall with all that Kovach stuff and then
I might walk by and like accidentally
put my hand up or something or might
lean on its tie my shoe or boom there it
is you're outside and you caught that
goes in the grass I walk 20 feet in the
direction not even think twice yeah so
that's why people have been saying these
lockdowns need to be lifted the same is
true for these a lot of criminals
house-arrest makes sense if they're
doing nonviolent offenders maybe like
drug offenses or something I don't know
that makes sense to me but I think the
bigger picture here what I'm trying to
bring up is ultimately it looks like a
general breakdown in social order you
know it's not about whether or not the
prisoners should or shouldn't be
released it's about the fact they are
being released
whatever yargh it might be it's not the
fact we got this to this story NYC nurse
who beat coronavirus pummeled robbed by
a group of thugs so in New York City you
get a nurse front line on the kovat gets
beat up and mugged saved by random
bystanders
oh she was saved by random by standards
is awesome that's great but not cops
then you get this of course not video
appears to show NYPD seizing young boy
for selling candy in the subway look how
sad this dude looks are you kidding me
man what are the what are the what are
the videos we get now it's possible that
we're not hearing about the good things
the cops do like helping you know Graham
across the street yeah there's there's
definitely good cops out there I know a
few myself
you know it's like but they exist but
I'm not talking I'm not talking right
now about the the percentage of good
cops versus bad cops okay I'm talking
about a breakdown in social order you
know we get videos of cops arresting
twelve-year-old kids or detaining them
whatever we get stories about a nurse
being beaten by random muggers no cop in
sight and now they eventually did arrest
on these guys so I don't act like that
cops have done literally nothing yeah
I'm trying to point out that if we're
gonna start letting people out of jail
if Philadelphia says we're not gonna be
arresting people anymore they did
announce that that's true they did while
ago yes yep they're like we're no coward
or postpone California was a California
they did it first and they're releasing
they're releasing inmates all over the
players setting the precedents like any
more people that see that's what I was
talking about robberies in New York
going up it's if you announce these
things if you tell everyone no one's
gonna be there the people that are
interested in those things are like yep
now I'm gonna go do it this is the
perfect time for me to go out and do
this that's what that's the point I have
for this right it's kind of it's it
seems like there are some stories that
look like government overreach
twelve-year-old kid getting detained
right I think the reality is with a
bunch cops being sick a bunch of cops
not wanting to get kovat so they're kind
of being distant you got commercial
burglaries are up seventy five percent
you got 1500 in New Yor
1,500 people being released from jail
this nurse is getting beat up kids are
getting stopped what is the message
being sent to bad people in New York
City you've got a governor telling you
you can't go to the gardening section
who cares it's snowing anyway but then
they'll stop this twelve-year-old kid
they'll tell you in Philadelphia we're
not gonna arrest someone for burglary or
for auto theft right more of them a
ticket for them to be arrested at a
later date oh yeah yep so you know you
don't have happening when they do this
I'm not I'm not gonna say I have any
stats to cite but when one jurisdiction
loses control people outside come in so
a Philadelphia says we're gonna give you
a ticket you come back later some dude
in Baltimore is like you don't take a
hop over to Philly yes okay that's not
gonna rest on just some stuff I mean
they won't they'll give us tickets but
we'll never to go to Philly again so we
simultaneously have it's really amazing
about the pandemic we're getting like
government overreach in some places and
like government under reach places right
yeah like it was that me mao's mention
in the political compass mm-hmm where
every faction got something they wanted
you know it's like the authoritarian
left is like the corporation's are dying
the libertarian left is like all right
well I can't remember exactly what
everyone wanted but you've got borders
tightening up for the authoritarian
right the libertarian right is saying
the government's you know spazzing out
everybody gets something they want yeah
it's crazy like there there's someone
sitting in a park by themselves and they
got a ticket like the the guy running on
the beach it's just like you know one
person I mean I get it you got to set
the precedent you know so if one person
goes then five people go then 100 people
go and it's like we don't like it but we
just heard that you are substantially
less likely to contract us outside
exactly so they're forcing people inside
where they're more likely to get sick
that's why thort Arianism doesn't work
it does what I was saying you know
everybody thinks they're smarter than
ever I don't I don't see the problem
with opening up anyway everybody's
washing their hands no one's shaking
hands everyone's wearing a mask like
what's really gonna change right why
wouldn't we just go back to work like
open things up wear a mask wash our
hands don't shake anybody's
stay away from each other like we can do
this isn't it it is a 20/20 we've been
doing this for a while I'm pretty sure
we can we can handle it
could you imagine the approval rating
for Donald Trump if he wasn't a potty
mouth yeah look look I know a lot of
people are like Tim who cares he's a
potty mouth I agree you know I'm an
adult and I'm selecting it whatever he
does have the media against them but if
you took his policies and his
environmental policies are terrible but
no one cares I do I know I think they're
terribly I agree it's like the worst
part about him yeah he's pulled back
tons of regulations for a moment
elections yeah it's really bad but but
here's my question to you have the
Democrats brought that up at all not in
the slightest
no nobody seems to be talking about
right it's weird you know it's like why
why not if you came to me and told me
that the Democrats were actually working
secretly for Trump's re-election I
believe it yeah I would totally believe
it look at they try to run it they try
to impeach the guy and he raises a
hundred million dollars his approval
rating skyrockets yeah it's like they're
trying again
like they're like junk you gar is saying
Trump should be impeached again it's
like don't you aren't they already
trying again do you remember what
happened last time you did this yeah why
would you the dude the dudes like
inadvertently being I I guess I just say
hanlin's razor yeah never attribute to
malice that which can be explained by
incompetence these people are so dumb
but you know in terms of what I was just
saying before like you've got these
you've got the Democrats and this is the
this is one thing I've brought up all
the time people say like Tim why do you
always write on the Democrats it's like
can you tell me one thing that they've
proposed recently orange man bad that's
right that's like now now of course so
there there are there are some policies
they've proposed and it's just not the
leadership well right I could probably
name some things that bernie has said
but thinking about what Biden says he
just he talks says Obama's name a couple
times says orange man bad a few more
times says um and that thing a few times
it really is no no but and then the
cycle repeats he says that thing that
you know and you know you know do you
know the thing good thing
but he's been getting worse I know man I
don't what I can't believe it I don't
want to deviate yeah sorry but but the
the I I think we can kind of wrap up the
segment but yet but the point I'm trying
to make is if we got these cities you
know acting like they have they have no
ability now to police properly yeah that
they can't arrest people because they
don't demand power yeah that's a problem
why are we seeing police then arrested
dudes jogging yeah or paddleboarding
attempt to right why are we seeing all
of this at a time where the telling us
they don't have the ability to do it why
are they locking down yeah
telling us to stay in our homes we can't
go out we got sacrifice mm-hmm and then
we hear stories about nurses getting
pummeled we hear stories about people
being released from jail you know I I do
have to say like you sure it sounds easy
to me to open back up everyone wear
masks wash your hands but I lived in New
York for a long time and the New York
subway system is packed tight and New
York it has a million millions of people
going million going through that every
day so if you took the subway system
sometimes your shoulder to shoulder so
it doesn't matter you wearing a mask
you're still sweating the summertime it
gets hot in there it's gross sometimes
and it's like does a petri dish just
waiting to happen
I see what you're saying Adam in your
call for reopening the government you're
saying we should purge New York and let
them all fight them whoa whoa you said
that I didn't those are your words well
as I was saying don't twist we should
open up no I just I like to look at all
sides of the coin
that's what nobody wants to say the
truth and the truth is we cannot have an
economy shut down permanently and we
cannot open up in a population density
area where people will die
guess what pick one you have to yeah you
can't have both hits at your career
right now we were talking about a month
ago like we just have which one is it
it's people are gonna die which which
way kills less people yeah that's that's
the only choice we have the cocktail
will die dr. oz got slammed because he
said we should reopen the schools or so
he said something like some people would
want to open up the schools because
we're looking at a two to three percent
mortality I think some people would be
willing to accept that that's the gist
of what he said and get torn apart he
apologized for it and I think maybe he
said it little callously yeah but I'm
not a fan of people trying to pretend
like the world is a bunch of foofy
Mallos and candy canes the reality is
guess what people gonna die yeah hey
Luna thing was look at we're animals
we're susceptible to this stuff and the
earth is you know we have to deal with
what happens on earth and that's it it's
like that's the thing we have to deal
with it and move forward not dwell and
yell at people and blame god that's like
on that hard times strong men yada yada
man you know you've got people unwilling
to accept reality it's it's it's
actually perfectly in line with the
healthcare as a human right
crowd yeah would I personally prefer
everybody to have access out there oh
you betcha course and then some yeah I'd
love mine if what you know you ever see
Elysium yeah right they got those beds
you Laennec sure is every disease yet oh
here's your cancer no oh there's
something wrong with you you're clear
now oh I'd love to give those to
everybody guess what they don't exist
I know so in this movie they try to make
it seem like the rich people just don't
want to share for no reason and all the
rich people are in space and they speak
French and all the poor people speak
Spanish Brielle is playing yeah that's
true but like this is how they view the
world like there's a magic wand that
will cure you and they just won't let
you have it
yeah and that's that's they tweet about
yeah that's what's ruined it feels like
they feel like they're and Liam they're
right somewhere out there there's this
magical cure everyone can just hear that
the rich people have that they can just
pop the pill and be fine it's because
they don't want to accept that people
die and we are not gods you know can't
stop it
yeah people die there was a story about
I think was Louisiana some kid had a
genetic yeah disease okay
they said the treatment the cure was
four million dollars yeah and so the
family demanded the state pay for it the
state was like we don't have four
million dollars for this and they
demanded the state pay for it I try
explaining this a lot of these people
when they don't want to hear the truth
I'm like you understand that there's no
cure for some diseases right okay if if
a company right now invented an
extremely risky and expensive treatment
to cure say you know like let's say we
could definitively cure leukemia boom
snap of the fingers and they don't and
had to do all this work build a new
machine called the chemo
Reiter and it was made of like
ridiculous parts it was built by you
know specialists and it costs a hundred
million dollars to build mind with
materials mined from the moon kind of
thing right and then they're like
everybody should have it it's a human
right now I'm sorry if you can afford to
operate the Machine by the way it cost
four million dollars to operate the
machine yeah pull the trigger one time
to cure leukemia four million bucks yeah
so we're gonna get as many people as we
can but it's not a right it's the it's
it's it's a technology the same as
anything else yeah and the whole health
thing kind of bugs me too because
there's so much self health care that
people don't deal with you know like
brushing your teeth getting enough sleep
eating enough food getting the correct
amount of nutrients from that food you
know I mean all of these think
exercising getting up and walking every
day it's like there's plenty of people
that don't follow these things and a lot
of those people are the ones going why
not free health care for everybody
well they don't I'm sick why shouldn't
why should I have to pay for this it's
like you're also not very healthy right
it's it's you know the health care is
health care isn't just the doctor giving
you a pill to swallow
yeah it's eating the right food it's
exercise exactly they don't wanna take
them carrier so they don't want to do it
so then what what happens when it comes
to the government what happens when it
comes to the chronal virus for one they
want the government to do everything you
know you do it just tell me what to do
and then they assume that there's a
magic switch that makes everything all
better that you know so it's funny there
are some people that are just the the
fakest you like what's that Ruben with
Jeff Jennifer whatever yeah she's
supposedly conservative she's not camera
oh okay yeah you got a camera you gotta
use it
I mean I don't I don't she can tweet
where she wants like chin cause of
whatever she wants but she tweeted like
the Trump death toll or something but
room and it was just like it was stats
about like if we close down a week
earlier how many people would have died
versus two oh two weeks later and it's
like I yes it's all Trump's fault all
the ways trans fault you were absolved
of all responsibility you don't exist
except of course when he did close it
down you were the person going
why is he doing this xenophobe yeah
exactly like wait what but now you're
saying now there's a list of death toll
blaming him yeah it's it's just it's so
I think you have these people who
believe that they're deserving of
everything that there's a magic wand to
cure all their problems and you get
people like her who kind of inflame and
exacerbate that mentality yeah because
if you look if if a person came up let's
say a person walked in this room right
now and said I think all Peter should be
free and then all 300 pizza pizza all
peaches to be free oh and then all three
of us immediately said that's not
possible who's gonna get the wheat whoa
whoa whoa whoa I don't know if that'd be
my answer free pizza sounds pretty good
it does sound good pizza man yeah so so
who's gonna make the dough I'm good to
make this yeah I mean you got me there
man he got me so these people live in a
world where they think it's like we're
talking about yesterday
the bridge is just there you know like
you go to New York and there's a bridge
just there for free for you to use for
free yeah you're gonna pay anything for
it you just walk right across it yeah
well some of the bridges for free to
walk across so to walk across it yeah
they're free to Walker well the tunnels
aren't free well I guess like the George
Washington yeah you know from the
jerseys if you're leaving New York if
you're leaving you're no no no if you're
leaving you're good yeah coming and you
got paid yeah yeah you know what they do
that keeps poor people out seriously so
is that a thing
or you just kind of this is our own that
out this is the like I guess I don't say
urban legend but like a common common
claim from people in big cities okay
it's all the way it always cost money to
come in it's always free to leave mmm
they charge you to come in it's not it's
not so much keeping poor people out
necessarily but it's to reduce
congestion and stuff like that okay but
yeah the poor people can't pay the five
bucks to drive into the city they'll
take a bus for two bucks something well
it's you know what it reminds me of like
the the music guy out on the street
always always sell it for something
because if someone buys it yeah they're
more inclined to listen to the CD as
opposed to let's uh let's let's let's
hit the nail on the head with the main
point of what we're talking about here
with with medical issues and and the
Crona virus pandemic we're gonna reopen
up yeah Andrew Cuomo says he wants to do
it yeah we are I think you look at
Trump's plan you look at the governor's
plan
everybody's trying their hardest to
mitigate the damage yeah it doesn't help
when you have partisans come out and
attack Cuomo or attack Trump and don't
just you know pass the blame of course
Trump gets it the worst than everybody
yeah there's but there's always those
people that are just shooting guns at
whoever is their target and it doesn't
matter who the target is there's us
person out there shooting guns at
everybody basic well I'm always
targeting the media for the most part
right the way the way I put it is I
think de Blasio got it the worst like he
was encouraging people to go out in New
York City into March Trump wasn't not
doing that Andrew Cuomo actually
rejected the de Blasio's assertion they
would shut down the city to get real
we're not gonna do it yeah you can
criticize all three of them I'll tell
you what we're trying to we're trying to
fight through this problem you know we
know it's gonna get bad people are gonna
lose their lives so I'll I will give my
respect to de Blasio I think he's trying
I don't think he's the best guy in the
world thing he's made mistakes but do I
think he's trying of course if you'd be
insane to think they want people to die
yeah drummers de Blasio Cuomo of course
they're trying let's let's let's let's
chill out a little bit let them do their
job whether it's a Democrat Newsom as
well Gavin Newsom and they and they've
had back and forth the president too but
all I see from so many people is this
there's like two things that overlap
Trump all the people who died it's all
Trump's fault and this could have been
solved without loss of life that's just
not true so if Cuomo wants to reopen
things and so does Trump and Trump said
here's my plan here's the phase it's up
to you guys yeah it's gonna get worse
we're gonna see waves probably will see
more loss of life nobody wants to admit
dr. Oz's to apologize for saying it
guess what do you want to reopen schools
what are you gonna do hide in your
basement and lock the doors it'll never
go away yeah so I don't I don't tell you
guys man it's like sometimes there's a
boogeyman that's really gonna come and
get you and you can't just hide yeah
I'll use I'll use one last analogy
that's very esoteric great when you're
playing Magic the Gathering and you're
scared your opponent has a counterspell
you can't just sit there doing nothing
you have to play through it that's my
style play through the counterspell now
everyone's like I have no idea what that
meant well you see you and
people would come into the hospital they
would come in with their parents and
their parent is very sick and they would
talk to them about their parent dying
and they were like well we had never
anticipated that this would happen to
our parent yeah it happens to everyone
news flash will die to quote to
paraphrase Fight Club on a long enough
timeline the mortality rate for everyone
becomes zero yeah becomes no he says the
life expectancy everyone becomes zero
it's like that ya know long enough
timeline guess what people die yeah I
guess some people want to live and your
see the movie the invention of lying
great movie awesome movie no that's
funny it's a photos aren't familiar
Ricky Gervais seal is it's it's it's
hilarious he lives in a world where no
one can lie movies are a dude sitting in
a chair reading history like an
encyclopedia entry yeah and one day he
discovers he can lie like an accident
he's like whoa and he tries to explain
to people where Elias no one understands
but there's a scene and and look I know
it might be spoiling it for people
didn't see it but it's a really old
movie yeah his mom's dying and she's
scared and she's like I don't want to be
nothing and he goes no no no no it's not
true
you're gonna see everyone you've ever
loved you're gonna be happy for all
eternity and she's like really he's like
yes yes and he's crying and sad just
trying to tell her whatever she needs to
hear and make her feel good yeah that's
the problem we have right now just in
general an inability to accept that life
is not always going to be perfect you
are not just going to wake up one day
with with you know a magic cure and a
million bucks and a check from the
government it's is not working that way
no if you want to eat good you got to go
work good if you want home if you want
to succeed you got to work for it
exactly you know you go do the work
everybody is just it out there you got
to get up and and focus on the goal that
you want and make it happen
everybody's so jealous man and never say
no jealous and and never let never let
those people affect you that's that's
also huge because there's no blood there
that are like oh I tried but then all
these people hated me so I just gave up
and it's like I think I'd rather not
care about those people cuz you just
said it they're just jealous they're
just they're just they're jealous
because they're not doing that they're
sitting there just pointing and yelling
because that's that's as bold as they
are able to get it's like I imagine
someone you know walks onto a field
a bunch of supplies and starts just you
know building away and they're building
a little like little tree fort mm-hmm
eventually they will have their little
tree for it yeah you know and they're
gonna be able to hang out in there and
you know read some comic books whatever
they want to do someone else instead of
you know hammering away is staring at
them saying it's not fair I want that
treehouse
well guess what dude if you started
hammering those pieces of wood up
against that tree in a month say my time
you'd have won yep but instead they just
complain about how they deserve it from
someone else
you should give us your tree house
because you have it dude I've had
friends tell me this it's like here's
the biggest red flag for roommates they
were like I said if we're we'll all
split the electric bill they argued to
me well we like it you know really hot
like 75 76 and I'm like I do not want to
be that at my place if you want to Jack
the heat up then you pay for it and
they're like well actually you make more
money than that so you should pay for
most of it oh wow really yeah that's
ridicu it's true story and I was like
nope no chance I'm at lling with these
people thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you